welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of the
falcon the winter soldier episode 6
the finale one world one people in which
captain america
sam wilson dresses up and home team
whites u.s agent john walker is back
black and sharon carter did to my
theories which he did to that black
smasher's face
look folks my favorite part of this has
always been to just go back through the
episodes and point out all the
interesting details that you might have
missed and this finale is
filled with little stuff that you can
gnaw on like sarah's tiny potato slices
or zemo's gross turkish delights
okay we open on the flagsmasher's
disruption of the grc vote
actually carly's voice over here is
actually the same line that she spoke in
latvia last episode
they're not going to stop
was more emotional than now they use an
alternate take where she sounded more
resolute and firm
then a little moment with bucky that i
loved
nice this officer respects bucky's
service and his rank
telling us that some people in this
world really do learn from the history
and cap smithsonian exhibit making it an
even bigger deal when isaiah's history
will later become restored
sharon carter uses the same mesh face
mask that natasha used in winter soldier
it also appeared in agents of shield now
while you could see
sharon's suspicious behavior in the
post-credits scene as a set-up for
secret invasion this mask to me signals
that
she herself is probably not going to be
a scroll because then she wouldn't
really need that kind of cloaking tech
right but then again apparently no one
cares about sharon's past history
so whatever notice how the flag smashers
use these smoke grenades that glow
green and then sharon talks about her
deadly mercury vapor
she says among other things that she
uses on that flag smasher that emits a
green smoke and then those locks that
they use on a truck doors have eight
claws and they're strong they take
several strikes of bucky's vibranium arm
to break
remember batroc supplied this gear
courtesy of
sharon after she hired him and sharon
called someone on the phone in the
post-credits scene
super soldiers might be off the menu but
we're about to have full access
to government secrets prototype weapons
you name it
i'm thinking one of sharon's trading
partners and the source of this tech
could be
ozcorp normally i'm hesitant to lean on
spider-man villains like green goblin
norman osborne in my mcu theories since
all those are sony properties
and marvel can really only do so much
with them in non-spider-man titles but
sony did just sign a deal with disney
plus that makes that kind of future ip
sharing a bit more likely and
by something for everyone sharon might
mean a team of weapons tech
manufacturers known for
green glowing grenades a weapon used by
green goblin and
eight armed reinforced metal gear that
you could see someone like doc
ock putting together and this comes
within a week of alfred molina talking
about his role as doc in spider-man no
way
home but before we continue thank you to
bessie shoes for sponsoring this video
bessie makes these knit sneakers that
are 100 waterproof and snow proof
they're super breathable so they don't
let any liquid in but they do let the
air move out
winter snow no biggie spring mud not
concerned summer rain showers
well might ruin my elaborate picnic
plants but they will not make my feet
wet bessie's shoes are super stretchy
they fit like a sock and they only weigh
175 grams
which is way less than the cheese log
i've made for my picnic and they're made
with this cool dimetex material that
keeps your feet warm and cold weather
and cool and warm weather and it's super
easy to clean with just a rinse of water
you know when the weather's nice i like
to lounge by the pool but sometimes i'm
just lounging too much and
plunk my shoes got all wet but hey
wouldn't you know it thanks to these
messy knit sneakers my little piggies
are
bone dry thanksy
these are some truly everyday shoes no
matter the weather of your activities
these shoes are perfect for you
this is the perfect gift for you and
your loved ones especially for the
upcoming rainy season
get them while they still have sizes and
you can thank me later
check them out in the link below and use
my code new rockstars to get 25
off your vessy shoes so sam wilson
swoops in with his new
suit
yeah now the music here evokes the steve
rogers cap thing but it is a variant
that is unique to sam
this suit's largely white design
reflects sam's look in the comics when
he becomes cap including the half cowl
that shield magnetically latches to his
back like it did with steve
and sam being in white here creates an
interesting contrast with us agent john
walker
it's the same but black
sam as a black man in a role
historically seen as a white man
walker as a white man now donning the
archetypal black hat but sam does not
leave us guessing
i'm sorry wait who are you captain
america i thought captain america was on
the moon yeah the guy calls back torres
it's conspiracy theory that steve rogers
was on the moon
this series never gave us an answer as
to what happened with old cap from
in-game kind of treated the mystery as
more of a joke because i guess these
disney plush shows can only do so much
mcu world building but for now i'm just
gonna go with cap
is in space with nick fury so as the
grcc diplomats are evacuated listen to
this voice flaring over the pa system
[Music]
group three will leave the air support
on the roof maybe
don't announce this while terrorists
have infiltrated the freaking building
like imagine if that happened at the
capitol uh actually maybe don't mentally
compare what the flag smashers are doing
to january 6
and just don't a flag smasher hands
bucky a phone with carly calling via
that flag smashers app
the app that bucky will later use to
trap the flag smashers
they must have thought 106 year old man
couldn't work the app they thought wrong
carly asks bucky i'm fighting for
something bigger than myself
have you ever been able to say the same
you don't think i ever fought for
something bigger than myself that's all
i ever tried to do
and i failed twice yeah bucky fought
freaking thanos you dummy
his two losses may refer to his losses
in infinity war
and in world war ii you could argue
though i don't really know if it's fair
to say he's lost that
really every fight this dude fights has
been over something bigger than himself
sam subdues batroc by kick flipping the
shield and then
tossing it out the window first to break
it before swooping back out to catch it
this is also kind of how he had to enter
the building by smashing the window with
the shield first
see if those were condensed i just given
him a vibranium head covering instead of
leaving his scalp weirdly exposed he
wouldn't have to worry about smashing
through the glass himself he's made a
vibranium at that point
sam uses red wing to scan the grc
hostages and on the screen you can see
her name
ayla perez she's a background in the
philippine air force with experience
flying both
apache and chinook helicopters chinook
helicopters are twin roaders that tell
sam that perez has experience with
multiple types of helicopters and that
he can trust her to climb into that seat
and pull it out of a dive even though
that would probably be very difficult
for anyone other than tom cruise to do
sam saves the nypd pilots shielding one
with his wings
and the cap shield on top showing how
the wakandans designed this
to be a perfect interlocking vibranium
seal john walker shows up with his
cosplay shield
his medal of honor welded on the inside
notice how this shield has a lighter
more tinny sound than the deeper
mystical hum of the vibranium
as bucky falls into the construction pit
he screams
echoing his scream as he fell from the
train in the first cap film
the scream that inspired his winter
soldier whale which we have not heard on
this show
since his wakandan campfire going clear
moment and since he is no longer haunted
bucky now
sticks the superhero landing oh hey by
the way our anarchy assembled shirt is
still available along with our amazing
new
zemo design though we are running low on
supply for both of those so you gotta
move fast you can support us this way at
newrockstarsmerch.com
so carly tries to murder hostages put in
walker at this crossroads
yeah notice composer henry jackman
brings back his theme from civil war
here to underline walker's come to jesus
moment choosing to save the hostages
instead of seeking revenge on carly
though i
should say after what he did in episodes
four and five for john walker it's not
really come to jesus as it is jesus
actually pulling away his mesh face mask
reveals manifesto underneath because
that guy's going to hell but walker's
choice is emphasized by what he does let
drop his cosplay shield it's beaten and
limp but when the truck
goes loose again it's the true shield
that lifts it
framing the shield like a rising sun
saving these lives
an inverse of the way john walker framed
it eclipsing nico
and ending his life sam uses his drones
for a boost similar to iron man's drones
in spider-man homecoming
really with this suit sam is truly a
fusion of captain america and iron man
with the vibranium tech of black panther
an onlooker watches this calling him
black falcon like the kid in baltimore
in episode two bucky catches the rebarb
spear i love how this dude catches
pretty much everything hurled at him on
the show
walker with the shield on the truck the
knife in episode 4 the shield again in
the fight last episode get this man a
goalie mask
and then sharon is revealed to be the
power broker
a twist that seems both overly obvious
but also pretty inconsistent with the
character's past behavior and timeline
we go all into it and inside marvel but
hey the good news is according to this
sharon carter is now apparently the
mcu's most brilliant mastermind who
also makes things weirdly hard for
herself and if that's the sharon you
love
cool now you could argue sharon never
explicitly declares herself the power
broker
without a super soldiers how much power
does the power broker really have
more than you so you're the power broker
but sharon kills batroc only because he
threatens to expose her
as the power broker to the world as a
woman behind the curtain she needs
anonymity and if she wasn't the power
broker here she wouldn't care what
batroc told people so sam shows up to
fight carly anchoring his wings in the
concrete similar to spider-man planting
his extra arms while fighting thanos but
sam avoids fighting her he does these
flips and somersaults the same ones that
we saw him training with last episode
so i love looking back on that training
as really defensive
conflict avoiding training carly says
die down
[Music]
no yes similar to iron man saying this
to the previous cap in civil war
stay down final warning yeah shame that
sam here doesn't say i can do this all
day but
i guess that's steve's line walker
quotes abraham lincoln
mercy bear is richer fruit than strict
justice
yeah the president who oversaw the u.s
civil war another sign that walker is
learning the lessons that these avengers
had to learn the hard way in their civil
war so carly dies in sam's arms holding
the hamsa pendant that she held at
mamadonia's deathbed and as sam carries
her body his outstretched wings evoke
that of an angel delivering the soul to
the afterlife or really john i'm a fist
dope because she's going to hell
i love how the reporters don't know what
to make of sam
captain falcon i wonder what sam's big
move in super smash
would be
[Music]
so sam lectures the grc leaders to
change
course telling them that they gotta do
better and if i can do better and you
can do better maybe we
all can do better hey pretty great
really even deeper than sam's great
points are the fact that we are seeing a
black captain america publicly speaking
truth to power
it is a core component to cap's
character that we saw when steve debated
nick fury and captain america winter
soldier or stood up to tony stark in
civil war and bucky acknowledges this
evolution
nice job cap thanks
bucky pat's the shield he is both
complimenting
sam by calling him cap and patting the
shield as a way of saying
nice job steve for choosing this guy and
the last time we see sam
in this suit on this series he soars
across the frame with the shield briefly
in close-up
gliding past us meanwhile the rest of
the flag smashers go boom are you
looking for this
detonated by osnick zemo's butler from
episode three
and this news gets to zemo on the raft
prison from civil war
he's wearing the same jumpsuits that
they all wore then on his shelf are a
few
books russian poet alexander pushkin and
views of nature by alexander von
humboldt i guess this is the alexander
shelf
meanwhile the book zemo reads looks like
the one he had in his cell in episode
three
fortune is a river which explores the
friendship between machiavelli and
leonardo da vinci in renaissance era
florence italy
now i previously speculated that this
book meant that the machiavellian zemo
had a secret partnership with some da
vinci figure in the shadows
someone like looks like our friend zemo
connor got the last laugh yes zemo's da
vinci was
defontaine since oznik likely could not
have arranged that bombing himself it is
clear val must have helped couldn't have
worked better if i planned it myself
well maybe i did
no i'm kidding i didn't or did i so the
fact that val has been in touch with
zemo
who's on the raft a facility overseen by
thunderbolt ross
tells us that our theory that val could
be assembling a team of anti-heroes like
the thunderbolts
or dark avengers may still be happening
and by saying the flag smashers deaths
is gonna save a lot of paperwork
redacting and shredding tells us that
she must be part of some shadowy
government division
as opposed to working for hydra or
something but val has suited up john
walker as us agent the dark-suited
assassin from the comics that we
expected him to end up as
interesting to note u.s agent also leads
the dark avengers later in the comics
and val ends by saying things are about
to get
weird so when they do
we're not going to need a captain
america we're going to need
a u.s agent weird
well one way to look at weird is that
val knows about the skrull infiltration
and that the secret invasion is coming
and in a world where no one trusts
anyone having an untrustworthy dark cap
is more valuable
but val also said last episode that the
government's ownership of the shield is
a legal gray area making me wonder if
she knows about old cap
and how he brought that shield from an
alternate timeline making it technically
the property of an alternate timeline
government so maybe the weirdness she's
referring to
is the coming multiverse crisis
something that we could see more of with
loki in the tva
meanwhile bucky makes true amends with
mr nakajima and officially crosses mr
nakajima's name off the list
a list whose names that we have broken
down in previous breakdowns and he
leaves that notebook as a gift for dr
rainer leaving the frame with an
empty couch and empty woods bucky is now
out of the woods
sam visits isaiah bradley again black
captain america huh
damn right and right as sam says this
behind him eli bradley enters the frame
eli is the future young avenger patriot
another black cat figure but for now
he's still waiting his turn
in line behind sam meanwhile behind
isaiah during the scene is interesting
graffiti the words why
me reflecting how both of these men had
the burden of captain america's legacy
thrust upon them now isaiah brings up
martin malcolm and mandela
of course referring to civil rights
leaders martin luther king jr malcolm x
and nelson mandela but my favorite thing
about this is this
atlanta neighborhood where they shot
this scene is home to where martin
luther king was born
the famous mlk house is visible at the
end of the street in episodes two and
five
so sam brings isaiah to his new addition
to cap's smithsonian exhibit including
this plaque that details the history
that isaiah told him about along with
this old photograph this shows black
world war ii soldiers that actually
inspired a panel in truth red white and
black i love how this
bookends the shot that we saw back in
episode one sam's reflection as he
stared at that shield in the display
case it was actually him realizing
people who look like him
have been erased from this history as
sam's translucent form in that scene
suggested
but now sam has transformed this from an
optical illusion
to a tangible reality with this statue
of isaiah bradley
and we celebrate with a family cookout a
reminder that fixing the wilson family
vote has always been a personal metaphor
for sam for restoring the legacy of the
shield which he has done
as curtis harding's on and on plays the
final credit revises the series title
to captain america and the winter
soldier then we get to this post-credits
scene with sharon receiving a full
pardon
to return to her old rank as agent 13.
the carter name has always been
synonymous with service
trust welcome home agent carter two
references there to
peggy carter sharon's great aunt who
will show up in what if
and hopefully a future film with steve
rogers in that alternate timeline
it was actually announced that a fourth
captain america film is in development
from the falcon the winter soldier
showrunner malcolm spellman but that's
probably going to follow sam wilson not
the chris evans steve rogers cap films
that may or may not be in development
and we end on another power broker tease
from sharon carter talking to someone on
the phone
maybe one of her major poor operatives
or some other criminal group from the
marvel world
hydra ten rings hammer aim oscorp
whoever this is it's most likely setting
up sharon to return in the series armor
wars which rhodey is going to star in
this miniseries about the weaponry of
the mcu getting in the wrong hands
but my favorite detail about sharon's
final moments
as she exits the courtroom the camera
suddenly slows down
and she looks directly at camera it is
as if she knows how much her power
broker reveal broke
us but i gotta hand it to you agent
carter i had my doubts
but it was you all along
hey i want to thank everyone so much for
supporting us throughout this breakdown
series
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter at ea boss follow new rockstars
and subscribe to new rockstars for
breakdowns of this
other marvel stuff loki really anything
that will break my heart by ralph boner
in my theories
boner bye
[Music]
you